só isso mais um pouco e dar um estilo
mais barroco
uai é o olha com essa adicional olha só
tá gravando vão pagar levem sabia e aí
galera esse campeonato bom você sabe
onde eu tô é claro que não sabe por que
que eu não falei com ninguém eu tenho
recebido aqui na cara de gabriel gabriel
ozéia javier ruiz vai ficar ligado no
canal da gente fazendo o que sempre
fazendo paródias esquetes vocês fala
sérgio busquets e andrés e o nome porque
isso vai dar frutos velho putz velho
aqui o canal do porto fec você clique
aqui para se inscrever o canal e é bom
você se inscrever porque se você não se
inscreveu não vou tirar foto de vocês
para o instagram e aí estava em
fortaleza eu fui pra casa e depois que
eu fui pra casa eu já vim para recife
logo e é o seguinte acho engraçado
quando a gente compra a passagem de
avião é um negócio a taxa de serviço
a passagem que desponta aí vai vamos ver
quando fico só passar de uma taxa de
serviço a 800 contas chegou num avião
que teria água e exclui propaganda do
verde conta como descobriu que discute
satânico é esse é o nome dessa vida tem
muitas muitas coisas que eu acho
estranho porque eu acho que eu acho
muito estranho que tenha alguma coisa tu
acha ruim é que toda a lógica do negócio
essa camisa aqui está furado ainda por
floria que foi atrás aqui comigo pro
time perdeu poder como atrás quando a
mãe vai encher meu saco quando tô
cagando não pior quando eu tocava não é
quando eu não tô cagando eu saio e a
jogar em casa na [ __ ] no dia tornam
homens falam com ela e talvez
convenci toneladas 5 não sei agora como
é que toda lado rita
esse menino carlos e toninho to dela com
a idéia
nela causa de merda acho que a vida
parece que bota camisa com day amor que
odeia quando entrou no banheiro é né
ela quer desapontar fazer negócio e
empurrando o chocolate para fora ea
minha mãe fica perguntando o que eu
estou fazendo é engraçado tem pergunta
ela pergunta é quem está fazendo de fato
não é é para entender já que a gente não
pode falar o que está fazendo
só que a mãe da gente ela tem uma coisa
que ela tem que obrigar a gente a falar
o que a gente tá aí você vai confiar e
fala e quando sai a sala cheia das tia
todo mundo conversa excelente falou o
cantor é a ilha só amanhã
amanhã eu tô meu deus ele está no bairro
jockey
eu to aqui fazendo gay eu tô eu tô
pagano
os shopping onde agora quem tem iphone e
agora também aí eu não tenho mais quer o
tempo eu sou o diabo não tinha assim
como muitas pessoas por aí eu dei porque
ninguém é o cara deve a que não tenha
enviado natural não só com isso sou a
mulher chega a beleza do facebook
ae - a pensar nela [ __ ] eu vi as fotos
na frente e bateu o peito é toda a minha
vida eu tenho o meu celular no modo
silencioso está ligado na perna não acha
de jeito nenhum
esperaram para seguir uma linha que é o
meu celular mãe achava lá muito boa pra
ele tem o dom da mãe pediu para falar
eu uso é tão falecendo
o beijo é daniel o'day o comando daquele
negócio que é um leite com um monte de
nomes você lançou a bunda mungunzá
cordeiro negócio e induz a ver e eu
odeio a galera acho que gosto de comer
tudo o que comia vou te comer mas não
existe isso usavam usar nunca usar é a
rota cara uma coisa que se chama mundo
usar não pode fazer nada de bem para a
humanidade aqui 10 680 responder quando
começa a bater o canadá 25
é parece uma cesta de basquete começa a
ficar mais comigo pô eu vou dizer uma
coisa eu estou puto que com enderson
hoje porque ele é a única pessoa no
mundo que tenha um perfil verificado
isso me irrita o facebook desde lá a
mulher dele indicou a mulher dele ficar
no total verificado com a extinta rádio
tok pesquisando que merda é verificado
se o bota já vota hoje eu roubei pela
roubo qualificado como usuário cardoso e
agora a gente quer saber de vocês o que
é que vocês mais odeia o que vocês acham
mais estranho na vida você e aquela
coisa né cara tô aqui em recife e já vi
embate logo aquela coisa do em recife
gravando o vídeo recife de você não ter
lá que neste vídeo você você é obrigada
a enfiar gabriel oliveira o gol dentro
de seu clube no facebook é legal que
você deu uma partida aqui né etapa que
ajuda nós aquela coisa e tal ataque
gabriel oliveira porto velho olha aí se
você quiser se inscrever no canal do
porto vai você quiser não é obrigado que
se não não vou tirar fotos você está
posta no instagram aqui ó
clique aqui para no canal dae e escreve
lá e é isso aí vai sair um vídeo também
no canadá pude ver com a minha
participação e vai sair muitos vídeos
legais e da ebr
bom e segue no twitter é o primeiro em
que a descrição do vídeo e curtir a
minha página no facebook também tá cara
vai ser muito da hora meio ano quem é
esse ponto eu tô conversando com a
galera da internet fica falando que eu
estou a estudar hoje e amanhã não vai
falar que essa escolha internet banheira
dynamo da futura ninguém é uma mãe muito
cara bom não vou mais carga baixa la
boca cala e me respeita me respeita me
esperança de uma mazela na [ __ ] tu tá me
chamando de culpa é toda minha
a deputada falou que essa história que
você afinal napo não falei nada você
falou 'você balançou a cabeça pra esse
povo tá assistindo aí o inter se ao
invés eu te pegar
eu nunca mais vai fazer vídeo para
internet nenhuma tamanho vai embora
dessa casa meu irmão não aguentou meio
após lavar após a taxa ficou bem